bom dia pessoal nome de aula de campo
seu aluno do curso de música que do
instituto de artes da unicamp e me
interesso bastante por musicologia nas
suas duas áreas na parte histórica da
musicologia histórica e na parte étnica
da china musicologia o trabalho que
desenvolvo ele utiliza a etnomusicologia
da qual nasce da necessidade de explicar
a música e seus acontecimentos através
da antropologia ou seja ela pega
questões que são culturais sociais ou
seja extra musicais que forma música e
que em certa medida pela música também
são formados
o principal campo de atuação desta nova
tecnologia são as músicas de tanta
popularidade folclóricos e é considerado
na música o campo ataque recente da
nossa maior evolução pós 1952 antes
disso os musicólogos mais conservadores
eles precisam estudar música européia de
concerto o principal diferencial da
etnomusicologia pra musicologia
histórica consiste em não se apoiar em
documentos históricos mas sim na cultura
e na sociedade pode escrever aquela
música ou seja deixa de lado um pouco a
música européia de concerto e dá espaço
para manifestações musicais pouco
estudados como por exemplo a música
indígena à música folclórica a música
africana a música do oriente médio entre
muitas outras
o que é o trabalho que desenvolvo ele é
um projeto ainda recente de uns três ou
quatro meses que tem como principal
objetivo obter material audiovisual ou
seja fonograma e também informações
sobre músicas folclóricas brasileiras
ele nasceu de conversas minhas com o meu
orientador thiago tavares que é doutor
em engenharia elétrica aqui pela unicamp
sobre a dificuldade de encontrar um
acervo sobre música folclórica e logo o
brasil é um país com o clube tão grande
que o original porém com um material tão
de espaço e pouco
divulgando material e até existe pois
desde o começo do século 20 alguns
pesquisadores apesar de poucos têm o seu
trabalho voltado para esse campo de
estudo
portanto se apoiando desde os
pesquisadores até os do presente
o trabalho ele tem o objetivo de
caracterizar localizar armazenar e fazer
à disposição do grande público desse
trabalho a forma de trabalho né
primeiro é feito a leitura de biografias
de ensino musical dos brasileiros sobre
música folclórica brasileira para que
isso ajuda a caracterizar essas
manifestações por assim não ficando uma
busca aleatória de informações
fazemos o nome de etno musical renomados
na área como por exemplo mário de
andrade câmara cascudo thiago de
oliveira pinto entre muitos outros
o segundo passo já lida a biografia
consiste na localização desses programas
esse material de áudio dispersa na
internet ele pode ser encontrado em
acervos ou em coletâneas e também existe
a possibilidade da digitalização de lps
presente na biblioteca da unicamp pois
ali khan possui um acervo muito grande
de lp
o terceiro passo é fazer a análise do
material com intenção de obter metadados
e descritivos ou seja nós ouvimos o
material de áudio é destacando algumas
características que achamos relevante
como por exemplo quais os instrumentos
utilizados que possuíam letra com o bpm
que a batida por minuto andamento
daquela música para que também
futuramente possa auxiliar o futuro
usuário da web site fazer sua busca
o quarto passo consiste no armazenamento
tanto do material de áudio quanto do das
informações no sistema
o quinto e último passo que estamos
começando agora consiste na análise
só que com o suporte computacional
também é feito pelo orientador que
consiste por exemplo pegar músicas em
comum a música com instrumentos nem como
qual a porcentagem de ocorrência desse
instrumento da do bpm de uma música é
possível determinar se ela vai possuir
não letra por exemplo músicas com
andamentos mais rápidos tendem a não
possui letra e música os fundamentos
mais letras lento tendem a possuir letra
alguns dados obtidos foram coletados
aproximadamente 320 quilogramas de
espécies nas coletâneas marcos pereira e
dicionários do solar do folclore
brasileiro onde os monogramas eles foram
agrupados nas regiões norte nordeste
centro oeste sudeste isso o agrupamento
foi feito por grau de parentesco entre
essas manifestações depois foi analisado
a instrumentação os instrumentos
presentes e foram agrupados em percussão
voz sopros e cordas onde todos os
instrumentos podem ser encontrado nas
mais diversas regiões porém com
predominância de alguns determinados
locais como por exemplo no norte na voz
nordeste sopros e percussão centro oeste
sudeste voz e cordas
isso nós depois foi analisado a presença
ou não de letras onde a letra foi
encontrada em toda região também de uma
forma bem distribuída porém com grande
destaque do centro oeste sudeste onde
todo foram analisados possuem algum tipo
de letra
por último foi analisado o bpn sendo
encontrado de uma forma bem equilibrada
bpm bem lentos de menos de 50 batidas
por minuto e alguns bem elevados com
mais de 120 batidas por minuto durante a
execução deste trabalho eu tive o tempo
ea oportunidade de aprofundar sobre um
tema que interessa muito e também de me
aprofundar um pouco mais da cultura do
meu país
e afinal foram esses estudos que guiarão
a pesquisa até aqui
portanto esperamos em breve ter em mãos
um material que sintetiza um pouco
desses estudos para entender uma falha
técnica e fazer uma posição do grande
público
queria agradecer a atenção de vocês
muito obrigado